i know you have tom brady burnout i was
just going to talk about that go ahead
yeah i mean
come on the guy's older he's winning
he goes to another team he proves the
fact that
you know he doesn't need belichick for
everything do you know what brady's
great at
he can win the game by himself or he can
manage the game
properly he does what he has to do
to win that particular game he's got a
sense okay do they need me to do this
today
or this today or maybe a little this
today you know sometimes that's not to
do that much the defense is playing well
sometimes the running game is good
always going to do is hand the ball off
you're saying the reason he's so great
he can adjust it doesn't matter what's
happening around him
is he the greatest athlete that ever
lived i mean you got muhammad ali who
was an incredible boxer you've got
jim brown a running back he'd have to be
up there jordan would have to be up
there but brady is the greatest winner
outside of bill russell who won 11
championships for the celtics
he's the greatest winner of all time
does brady's success
take away from belichick's legacy
but he does right most of the great
teams that win
multiple championships have the coach
quarterback
in sync where he got the hall of fame
coach and the hall of fame quarterback
and what brady was able to do here that
is very significant
is he went somewhere else and his coach
of the decent brucerians
is not a hall of famer so he went to
tampa as the hall of fame quarterback
without the hall of fame
coach and still won belichick
lost his hall of fame quarterback and
he's the hall of fame coach he's a great
coach we're on how great he is
but he lost the hall of fame quarterback
and he has yet to prove
that he can win without the hall of fame
quarterback now the one thing i would
say
belichick is gonna like you and me he's
never gonna quit you can tell me five
years
you and i will be doing this for a long
time better check when better check
would never quit
he's 68 years of age he loves it and he
will win another one now he is going to
be motivated because brady went without
him
he can deny it until the cows come home
he's competitive i mean nobody's gonna
don't you don't you think i wanted to
prove that i could do this show without
mike
yeah it's the same prince that's the
same principle better check wants to
show that he can win without brady
and so he will stay there for another 30
years to go out there and try to win a
super bowl that
so he what your prediction is he will
chase that dream
of winning and he'll win one